and it fundamentally comes down to the
core drive to
be financially well-off i think this is
still a very
deep-seated need to sustain one's career
in such a challenging job right there's
so many ways that you can make money
outside of recruitment the only reason
why you would use recruitment as a
vehicle for wealth
is if you truly have the commercial
acumen to understand how this industry
works
so i think it's got to be someone who's
business savvy who has probably seen the
world a little bit
who understand you know what a typical
job looks like and how recruitment is a
completely different
and unique beast of a job how you look
at business
and how you want to grow your business
there are a lot of people out there
that are shady and that like to take
shortcuts early on in recruitment
i realized that earning people's trust
and living off of their goodwill
is how is the easiest way to build a
recruitment practice
it's just simply smart business to treat
people well
and to give them good service and to
tell them to spread the word for you